en 1687 newton publiait les lois de la
gravité et montera qu'elle prédisait les
trajectoire elliptique des planètes
autour du soleil ou presque
il réussit à démontrer cela dans le cas
où la planète était le seul objet à
orbiter autour du soleil
on parle de système à deux corps
cependant quand ils cherchent à
appliquer les mathématiques de la
gravité à des systèmes à trois corps ou
au système solaire tout entier il tomba
alors sur un os
il fut incapable de déduire la stabilité
du système solaire de ses propres
équation pour newton de tels calculs et
est surhumain
il fallait la présence d'un grand
horloger un dieu pour remettre
régulièrement le système solaire en
ordre et préserver l'élégance et la
perfection des corps célestes
il aura fallu tout un siècle pour qu'un
grand génie défi enfin cette intuition
de newton et ce génie c'est pierre simon
laplace la place la place développe pas
une théorie du calcul perturbe hâtif
pour suggérer que système solaire
n'avait nul besoin d'un grand horloger
pour préserver son ordre les lois de la
mécanique et de la gravité suffisait à
expliquer l'ordre des cieux d'ailleurs
selon la légende napoléon bonaparte
aurait dit à la place newton a parlé de
dieu dans son livre j'ai parcouru le
vôtre et je n'ai pas trouvé son nom une
seule fois ce à quoi la place aurait
alors rétorqué citoyens premier consul
je n'ai pas eu besoin de cette hypothèse
alors si cette légende est sans doute
fausse la place semblait alors avoir
néanmoins fait basculer la philosophie
naturelle vers une vision mécanistiques
du monte en montrant que les lois de
newton était suffisante à la mécanique
du monde
la place introduisit un déterminisme
radical et contre intuitif dans son
essai philosophique sur les probabilités
pierre simon laplace écrivit ainsi une
intelligence qui un instant donné qu'on
ne traite toutes les forces dont la
nature est animée et la situation
respective des êtres qui la composent si
d'ailleurs elle était suffisamment vaste
pour soumettre ces données allen
lise embrasserait dans la même formule
les mouvements des plus lourds encore de
l'univers et ceux du plus légères atone
rien ne serait incertain pour elle et
l'avenir comme le passé serait présent à
ses yeux cette intelligence est ce que
l'on appelle désormais un démon de la
place selon la place le démon de la
place saurait prédire tous le futur à
partir d'une connaissance du présent de
l'univers car l'état présent de
l'univers détermine son futur en ce sens
l'univers est déterministe et alors on
pourrait se demander pourquoi est-ce que
la place défend le déterminisme dans un
essai philosophique sur les probabilités
bien pour en savoir plus je vous invite
à lire ce frais de twitter que j'ai
écrit à ce sujet pour la place les
probabilités ne sont pas là pour décrire
des phénomènes fondamentalement
aléatoire de notre monde
elles sont là pour décrire l'étendue de
notre ignorance et ça c'est un peu le
fondement philosophique du pays via nice
mme devrait d'ailleurs peut-être plutôt
renommée de probabiliste l'appelation
quoi qu'il en soit au début du 20e
siècle
le déterminisme la place tien triompha
en physique qu'il s'agisse des lois de
l'électromagnétisme ou de la relativité
générale d'einstein la physique semblait
défendre unanimement une vision purement
mécanistiques et déterministe de notre
univers selon cette vision le présent
détermine le futur et puis voir les
bizarreries de la mécanique quantique en
particulier pour expliquer des
phénomènes comme les fentes de young la
radioactivité ou l'airé spectrale il
semblait utile d'invoquer les lois des
probabilités
vous avez peut-être ainsi entendu dire
que en mécanique quantique un électron
et généralement dans une superposition
d'états physique et que lorsqu'on mesure
disons la position de l'électron cette
superposition s'effondre pour donner
lieu à une unique position de l'électron
mais plus étrange encore cette position
de l'électron semble fondamentalement
aléatoire elle varie d'une répétition de
l'expérience à l'autre et selon la
mécanique quantique la position future
de l'ailé
on semble indéterminée par l'état
physique présent de l'univers ou plutôt
ça c'est l'interprétation dit de
copenhague de la mécanique quantique
car elle fut promue par le physicien
danois niels bohr pour qui il suffisait
de faire des théories prédictive et il
n'était pas nécessaire de philosopher
outre mesure sur le réalisme de nos
théories étrangement cette
interprétation de niels bohr contraste
beaucoup avec l'interprétation de
copenhague est telle qu elle est le plus
souvent enseigner et vulgariser
aujourd'hui ou des physiciens affirment
parfois sans hésitation que la mécanique
quantique prouvent que le monde n'est
pas déterministe ya des jours j'aimerais
vraiment interdire l'utilisation du mot
prouvé par les scientifiques
d'autant qu'il existe des
interprétations de la mécanique
quantique qui elles sont déterministe
par exemple la théorie de long deux
pilotes de baume de brogues est une
théorie physique parfaitement
déterministe et qui fait les mêmes
prédiction que l'interprétation de
copenhague sur l'ensemble des
expériences physiques testé à ce jour
donc dire que la mécanique quantique
prouvent que le monde n'est pas
déterministe c'est allait vraiment vite
en besogne en fait seulement 49% des
experts adopté interprétation de
copenhague de la mécanique quantique
on est donc très très très loin d'un
consensus scientifique et qui plus est
la plupart des autres interprétations de
la mécanique quantique et semble même
déterministe ou du moins compatible avec
le déterminisme bref l'existence d'un
hasard fondamental c'est un sujet
complexe sur lequel les plus grands
experts de la planète sont en désaccord
mais il ya pire
la découverte de la théorie du chaos
rend la question de l'existence d'un
hasard fondamental encore plus complexe
dans les années 60 les mathématiciens se
sont rendus compte que des systèmes
déterministe très simples comme disons
le jeu de la vie de conway avait des
comportements extrêmement sophistiqués
des comportements qui semblent
aléatoires ainsi un système purement
déterministe peut largement semblait
aléatoire y compris aux yeux de la
physique
cette théorie du chaos suggère en
particulier que l'intuition limitée du
physicien et probablement un bien
mauvais guide pour déterminer si le
hasard existe vraiment de manière
fondamentale au mieux le physicien ne
peut que dire que ces modèles les plus
utiles invoque le hasard mais selon le
proverbe bayésiens tous les modèles sont
faux en fait si on veut savoir si le
hasard existe vraiment de façon
fondamentale
il convient certainement de d'abord
mieux comprendre l'épistémologie c'est à
dire la façon de transformer des données
en savoir or comme on l'a vu dans les
deux derniers épisodes
toutes les données semblent en fait
équivalente à une longue suite de 0 et
de 1
on avait même estimé que l'ensemble de
toutes les données auxquelles une
conscience humaine aura eu accès dans sa
vie aux présentes probablement autour
d'un téraoctet soit mais milliards 2 0
et 2 1
ok imaginons que je vous donne
maintenant accès à 1000 milliards 2 0 et
2 1 ça fait un peu beaucoup donc disons
mille 0 et 1 pour commencer déterminer
si le monde et déterministe ça
reviendrait à se demander si cette suite
2000 0 et 2 1 a été générée par du
hasard est ce que vous voyez comment
faire cela
peut-on vraiment inférées de nos données
sensorielles l'existence du hasard le
premier à s'être posé sérieusement cette
question semble être le logicien père
martin 9 en 1966 et à en croire une
équipe et dia c'est même le seul à être
parvenu à donner un sens rigoureux à la
notion de hasard fondamentale ou en fait
pour aujourd'hui je ne vais pas
expliquer exactement la notion
introduite par martin hoff que j'ai
d'ailleurs déjà expliqué avec teva
blanchard dans cette vidéo
au lieu de cela je veux insister sur
l'aspect philosophique derrière la
proche de martin 9 avec même une
perspective un peu plus générale donc je
m'excuse auprès des puristes et des fans
inconditionnels de martynov bref
l'astuce de martin hoff fut de remarquer
que l' inverse le hasard semble être la
régularité
or si je prends le mou régularité au
sens littéral il revient à l'existence
de règles sous jacente hors une règle ou
du moins une règle de calcul
c'est finalement un algorithme
ou pour martine 9 le hasard était ce qui
ne peut pas s'expliquer par le calcul
par exemple la suite 1 2 4 8 16 32 et
ainsi de suite n'a rien d'aléatoire au
sens de martin 9
parce qu'il existe un algorithme très
simple pour la généré cet algorithme est
par exemple l'instruction qui dit prends
le dernier nombre est multiplié par deux
c'est le succès prédictifs de cet
algorithme très simple qui nous amène à
dire que cette suite n'est pas aléatoire
de la même manière la suite 1 1 0 1 0 0
1 0 0 0 1 0 0 0 0 1 0 0 0 0 0 et ainsi
de suite
c'est une suite qui elle non plus n'a
rien d'aléatoire au sens de martin hoff
et je vous laisse réfléchir à comment la
générés avec un algorithme très simple
mais alors le problème si on suit les
pas de martin 9
c'est que tout de suite finie paraît non
aléatoire en effet une suite finie peut
être générés par un algorithme très
simple qui se contentent de réciter les
chiffres de la suite
par ailleurs si la suite finie était
vraiment aléatoire alors il faut
s'attendre à ce qu'il soit possible que
par chance elle soit égale à une suite
très prévisible comme celle dont on a
parlé plus tôt
en fait le hasard de martin 9 n'a de
sens que pour les suites infinie or nous
autrement ne pouvons pas lire les suites
pinaire infini à cause de nos limites
cognitives et d'ailleurs si l'on en
croit la thèse de church turing les
ordinateurs non plus dès lors force est
d'admettre que la notion de hasard
fondamentale ne peut pas être déduite
par une épistémologie qui se fonde sur
une quantité finie de données et comme
j'ai tendance à penser que seules de
telles épistémologie sont pertinentes
pour nous autres humains mais aussi pour
les machines
j'ai envie de dire que la notion de
hasard fondamental n'a simplement pas sa
place en épistémologie se posait la
question de l'existence de hasard
fondamentale s'est posé une question au
sujet de laquelle on semble garantie de
ne jamais pouvoir faire de progrès bon
qui plus est on peut se demander si
l'existence d'un hasard fondamentale a
vraiment une utilité quelconque
typiquement on se pose souvent la
question du rapport entre les licences
d'un art fondamental et le libre arbitre
mais à bien y réfléchir une décision qui
ne serait due
à un hasard fondamental ça ne serait
sans doute pas vraiment du libre arbitre
typiquement aussi mes décisions étaient
durs un art fondamental devrait
forcément suivre les lois du hasard
comme la loi des grands nombres fiq en
fait me comprendrait énormément dans mon
libre arbitre
d'ailleurs je ne sais pas si c'est
rassurant ou non mais nous autres
humains sont en fait très mauvais pour
générer un pur hasard en fait martynov
démontra même que même si on dispose
d'une suite infinie de données il est
impossible de décider avec une machine
de turing
si la suite on tient un hasard
fondamentale le hasard fondamentale est
incalculable
bref le hasard fondamentale semble être
une notion veine mais alors la théorie
des probabilités
certes elle vraiment à quelque chose
clairement si l'objectif des
probabilités et de décrire un art
fondamental
j'ai envie de dire qu'il s'agit en effet
d'une théorie vaines cependant au lieu
de disserter sur un concept à la fois
incalculable et peu utile on peut plus
raisonnablement suivre les pas de la
place la place est noté que la théorie
des probabilités et remarquablement
efficace pour décrire notre ignorance et
notre connaissance dans ce cadre ce qui
importe n'est plus le hasard
fondamentale ce qui importe c'est
l'incertitude due aux limites de nos
connaissances et ça c'est un hasard
qu'il est bel et bien possible de
dompter est urgent de maîtriser et pour
cela il est indispensable de s'immerger
dans le monde fantastique régie par les
lois des probabilités
l'anr fois on avait estimé la taille
d'une vie humaine à quelques téra octets
et docteur d'état fait remarquer que
dans ce terrain était il ya plusieurs
sources d'informations différentes
certaines viennent de la vue d'autres de
l'odorat ou autres encore et se
demandent s'il faut pas aussi en prendre
en compte l'origine de ses sources
et est ce que les métadonnées qui vont
étiqueté du coup l'origine des sources
ne représente pas finalement beaucoup
d'informations mais la réponse est en
fait non si vous regardez par exemple
sur votre ordinateur les différents
fichiers musiques vidéos ou autres
en fait dire si un fichier est un
fichier musique autres c'est juste une
extension de poing mp3 en fait un peu
plus que ça avec des en-têtes de
fichiers mais toujours est il que
l'origine en fête ou là
nature de la source d'information est
généralement facile à décrire en
quelques beats d'information seulement
et surtout cette quantité d'informations
est beaucoup plus faible que le contenu
lui-même de l'information qu'ils soient
visuelles ou autre ainsi lorsqu'on
inclut en plus les métadonnées en fait
la quantité totale d'information d'une
vie humaine ne change pas beaucoup
elle reste de l'ordre du téraoctet nick
l'homme habillé on lui demande si le
côté in et n'a pas été négligé par la
vidéo précédente en particulier est ce
que finalement l'information à travers
l'adn ne compte pas lui aussi en fait
oui oui ça compte énormément
mais on peut également estimer la
quantité d'informations qui vient par
exemple de l'adn la dnc pour un corps
mince et 3 milliards de lettres qui
correspond donc à quelque chose de
l'ordre du gigaoctet
or un gigaoctet c'est un millième de
toute l'expérience de vie d'un humain
qu'on a calculé l'anr fois et donc non
ça ne change pas du tout l'ordre de
condor de l'ensemble des données qui
correspondent à une vie humaine
je rebondis sur cette réflexion puisque
du coup elle est très intéressante pour
faire différence entre l'aïe qui est
l'hymne est d'une certaine manière selon
nos estimations il ya un rapport milles
entre les deux ce qui suggère que la qui
est de servir beaucoup plus important
que l'ine ont bien sûr ce n'est pas tout
à fait le cas puisque si on a un
algorithme stupide et qu'on lui donne
beaucoup beaucoup de données en fait ça
ne suffira pas à faire de cet algorithme
stupide
un algorithme puissant donc ce n'est pas
juste une question de quantité c'est
aussi une question de qualité quelque
part mais à cela j'ai aussi envie de
rajouter que ce qui est vrai a dominé
est également vrai de l'acquis la
qualité des données informationnel est
tout aussi important que la qualité des
données qui décrivent l'algorithme qui
est suivi par notre cortex cérébral
colligées fait la remarque que les
algorithmes sont beaucoup moins bon
aujourd'hui que les bébés pour
comprendre les données auxquelles
ils ont accès et à ce sujet je vous
recommande vivement les excellents cours
de 5 cela ce domaine aux cages de france
c'est vraiment absolument fascinant d'un
membre c'est très balisé en plus alors
ce qui est important de voir c'est que
la coopération que faith and then dans
son livre que je n'ai pas lu en train de
spéculer sur le contenu du livre mais je
devine que la distinction que ferrer
stanislas dehaene est en train bébés
d'aujourd'hui est un algorithme
d'aujourd'hui - a priori les bébés du
passé et de demain vont pas beaucoup
changé mais par contre les algorithmes
le ont énormément évolué au cours des
mêmes deux dernières années donc c'est
dire que quand on compare bébé
algorithmes faut faire attention avec l
algorithme on utilise comme point de
comparaison
en particulier il ya pas mal de raisons
de penser au repos notamment vers les
travaux de georges tenenbaum qui est
d'ailleurs beaucoup cité par stanislas
de haine lorsque les algorithmes qui
font ce qu'on appelle du belize anis
mili hiérarchique
on finira pas en parler dans cette série
en fait on a des algorithmes qui sont
très capables d'apprendre dans
énormément de contextes différents des
modèles très généraux pour ensuite à
mieux comprendre les données
donc il se pourrait que des algorithmes
suffisamment parisien est en fait les
mêmes capacités que les bébés et de
leurs sons en croit la case de torture
et ne peut imaginer très raisonnablement
que cela finira par être le cas
puisqu'il n'y a aucune raison que le
cortex cérébral humain soit la manière
optimale d'analysé des données et
j'espère que vous avez aimé cette vidéo
et que vous avez senti l'importance des
vidéos précédentes et de raisonner en
termes d'information et de flux
d'informations finalement si on veut
répondre à des questions comme
l'existence du hasard fondamental c'est
certainement la preuve la plus fiable
pour y arriver la chose très important
que l'on a vu dans cette vidéo ici c'est
qu'il semble avoir un lien assez
finement talent iii algorithmes et
probabilités et c'est un lien qui va
grandement talent pour avancer vers ce
que j'ai appelé le puritanisme dans mon
livre est avant d'en arriver aux purs
balsamique en fait va être utile de
mieux comprendre l'informatique
théorique les fondements de l d'eau et
inique et la prochaine fois on va parler
justement d'un des aspects les plus
intrigants de l'algorithmique puisque je
vais vous parler d'un an
mystérieux qui contient tous les secrets
des mathématiques mais qu'on ne peut pas
calculer
si vous avez aimez cette vidéo pensez à
la ligue avec mon cal partager conseils
aux abonnés pourront compter sur
l'épisode merci aux supporteurs dont et
j'espère que nous serons là la prochaine
fois bref vous voyez que le hasard le
plus total peut parfois faire naître des
formes parfaitement déterminé que ce
soit la trajectoire en ligne droite dans
ce premier exemple où que ce soit le
cercle dans ce deuxième exemple pourvu
qu'on le regarde de suffisamment loin le
hasard fait émerger des formes
inéluctable indécise où elle martine le
décret bradshaw aucun essai that we
should considère nord de cette ville
tess base de cette phase effective
test.com piotta voltaire